[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits
I'm link and I'm red this week at the
differently shaped tables and our own
homes we're going to be exploring the
answers that you gave to our question
that we put out on the social media
which was what's strange unusual or just
completely normal things are you doing
the past the time during quarantine yeah
I've been looking forward to this
conversation because I mean we've been
conversing about how we're dealing with
this and of course we'll continue to do
that but I've just been curious how
everyone listening has has been coping
with with this situation as as the weeks
lengthen and as the reality sets in
they're definitely they're definitely
linked here they are I think they're
literally getting longer each we yeah
yeah so how am i holding up
hey you holding up yeah it's your hairs
growing I mean mine has been growing for
a while but you found our science yeah
it's changed yeah - sort of reached a
certain stasis even though it slowly
evolved in the years yeah you know so
well what about those days I'm not
really motivated but here's the thing it
this the side part well I'm not doing a
side part the side regions of my hair
are the are the are the issues and so
instead of saying you know I'm gonna cut
this and I might really screw it up I'm
just saying instead of it coming down or
just slicking it back which I tried that
for a little bit now it's just like I'm
a puff at a little bit well I was like
tucking it behind just looking it back
you know and trying to keep it at bay
with it with my glasses and now I'm just
like well ever since we recreated that
big puffy hair photo and you did you're
like College mohawk photo I'm like I'm
just gonna go puff here shouldn't try to
change it exactly I think that's my
mentality in
this thing is taking what comes to me
and saying this is now a part of my
lifestyle I have a new lifestyle
and I'm trying to adapt to it and like I
said some days are better than others
for me and I do think some of what the
mythical beast can comment that they
were doing and how they were adapting to
this lifestyle some of it resonates with
me
some of it is a polar opposite of me
which might resonate with you so I'm I'm
excited to get into it
I do want to tell you about the dream
that I had last night
and please do maybe get an
interpretation Oh
again I don't know what percentage of
your biscuits start out with some sort
of bathroom humor more than I would like
but I can't help but let dream about you
go in there again and I mean it's kind
of gross but it's also redeem okay so in
my dream I was at a large high school
and I think that it might have been it
was supposed to maybe have been our high
school Hornet central but it was
completely different him much bigger it
was like from today but I actually feel
like it was what the school is going to
be like post virus-like when everybody
comes back okay you're gonna go back to
high school after this is over maybe as
a teacher I don't know and probably not
as a student so I I had to use the
restroom in my dream which happens all
the time but usually but you were a
student no I was I was like visiting for
unknown reasons but I was definitely not
a student it wasn't one of the I'm back
in high school dreams which I have had
number one or number two that's the
interesting thing so I've had many many
many dreams in my life where I had to do
number one right and then you wake up
and you're like man I got it finished in
trouble and and or you maybe you already
had well no well I don't want the bed
anymore I went to bed until apply seven
or eight so my I was a bed-wetter for
but I haven't wet the bed in the double
digit ages at all
and that'll purp not accidentally and
what okay can't please keep going and so
one of the what usually happens is I'll
have to pee in in my dream I'll find a
place to urinate and then I'll begin to
urinate in the dream but then I'll still
have to urinate because I'm actually not
urinating in real life right germinating
in a dream boy that's that is oh I see
dancing with the devil but I've never
again has an adult man peed the bed in
that fashion double digits but in this
dream last night at harness central in
the future I had to take a crap and have
you crapped in the double digits uh no I
have I have crapped my pants but that
was on the way to Dollywood one time
I've never done it in my bed and so I I
go into the the men's locker room and it
was a it was vast it was just absolutely
vast and in the middle of the locker
room there were just multiple toilets
multiple stalls as if this bathroom had
been designed for me to take a poop in
like you know I'm saying it it was like
my dreamscape where many options existed
for toilets okay but I go into the stall
and there's a seat like a toilet seat
but underneath the toilet seat there is
like a screen there's no plumbing
there is a screen like a square like a
net like a colander like a colander that
won't let anything look solid go through
it's like a it's like a urologist sifter
to get two stones down like a pool net
okay
like a pool net that catches your poop
and then I look over in the corner and
there is a charcoal
fire what yes there's a charcoal fire
where you're supposed to burn the poop
after you die at least is what I
inferred in the dream I was like oh
there's no plumbing in the future
they don't have plumbing the funny thing
is is that I thought it was about toilet
paper but it wasn't about toilet paper I
didn't see any toilet paper but that
wasn't what I was thinking I was like
man I'm gonna have to crap in this net
and then burn it in my old high school
and kind of cool I'm not prepared for
that and so he started getting stressed
so I walked out of the bathroom but then
I still had to take a crap so I walk
back in the bathroom and in the moment
where I was committing to the BM I woke
up and I was not interestingly in need
of a BM in real life that is weird that
is but was there and was there a net in
your bathroom well I'm thinking about
putting one in yeah and burning it and
that's it that's a way to keep your
house warm well that's what they did on
the plains back in the day they would
when there were no trees on the prairie
buffalo she had Buffalo chips they would
also make their home place yeah really
it's kind of a small home I guess it
were a lot of Buffalo they didn't take -
dig into it they used him like bricks
yeah cuz once it once it dries that
stuff that's stuff nice and ready - it
also lose you have to have a distinct
and when it dries you have to have a
drying zone you just can't you just
can't flop it out of the net into a
furnace unless it's already burning if
it's like a blazing furnace was there
already
no there was it was there already ablaze
there was a small fire small fire okay
yeah they might what a doused it hmm so
what does this mean yet please tell me I
mean there's definitely what I mean
there's a lot of toilet paper talk
happening a lot of a lot of there's a
lot of newfound anxiety around doing
number twos for that
for most people but I know we're both
working the bidet so I don't think
you're I don't think you I have you and
I know you've got a lot of toilet paper
personally I don't have in cerned about
that I don't have and I would be like it
wouldn't feel cool to be experiencing
this in your dream like if you were
experiencing this in real life you'd be
like like you got to come in here just
like you're telling me about the dream
but in the dream you were you were
freaked out by it well I didn't want to
carry my poop within a net across a
locker room and be seen I just said
that's just something that I don't want
to do anyway and I don't think that
makes me an especially anxious person I
think that makes me norm no I have no
actually using the bathroom it's not a
problem for me never has been but
bringing the poop out into the open and
moving it across a public space that
that is a problem for me hmm you don't
want people seeing your log yeah mm-hmm
okay yes so this is a vulnerability
issue oh this is definitely yeah this is
definitely your there's something inside
of you that some poop needs to come out
and and but you know what it comes out
people are gonna see it but well it's
gonna take people seeing it and that
vulnerability for you to be able for you
to destroy it for you to burn it for the
good of everyone that you live with so I
actually think oh if you think this is
my house yeah I think you need I think
you need to explore being vulnerable
about something with your family members
the people that you're spending day
after day after night after night with
there's a level of intimacy that you've
never had with your immediate family and
neither have I and I think that's what
it is I think I think you're afraid
they're gonna learn things about you
that are gonna stink
that's pretty good right I'm glad you're
not a therapist that was that is good
and hey by the way I think it applies to
me too well I'm just saying that in a in
a in a professional therapeutic setting
you would want someone you can't you
just you know what you just did you just
acted like a TV therapist or a therapist
from movies and television where they
always tell you what's wrong with you in
the movies but in reality they let you
discover what's wrong so you could have
led me bring got tired a little bit but
you just said it and so I actually can't
accept it
because I didn't I didn't come to that
conclusion so yeah I listen to the
theater and that's another problem we
have you can't accept wisdom I do want
to I just crapped into your net and you
don't want to burn it that's exactly you
crashed into my net that that's yes yes
a I've been trying to - I want you to
interpret it you didn't say I would like
to clock into a therapy session I should
have known that I was stepping into it
literally I do want to give an update on
the TP situation though I don't know if
you saw the article that Feldman posted
in the black I saw it I saw it I didn't
read it because underneath it it said
six-minute read and I was like you know
me I'm gonna think of all the other
things I could do in six minutes and
you're deflecting but yeah let's just
move on no this is actually I um want to
talk about because the toilet paper
thing I don't know why I hadn't thought
of this and I don't know why I hasn't
been mentioned but one of the things
that is driving the toilet paper
shortage which continues yeah isn't I
mean panic buying is obviously
contributing to it and the perception of
panic buying which leads to more panic
buying in hoarding is a part of it my
in-laws mailed us a big box of toilet
paper because we are about out and
Christie was telling her mom that and lo
and behold
they sent us a box I was very grateful
well but you know what the problem
actually one of the major problems is
the fact that we're all crapping at home
and not at work
and so the toilet paper suppliers supply
you know commercial and they also supply
you know with the grocery stores and so
most bitten big businesses are getting
their toilet paper supply now I think
mythical last time I checked people go
hungry here on toilet paper that's how
policy bring your own net is going to be
the new policy yes right there's gonna
be a fire in the bathroom and a net and
you got to be it's gonna be warm in
there smell a little odd but basically
it's the commercial toilet paper that's
sitting on the shelves not being used I
mean I didn't think about it in terms of
toilet paper I thought about it in terms
of water usage I was like hmm
everybody's at home I bet you our
electric bill and water bill is gonna go
up but our electric bill and water bill
at the studio is gonna go down you know
because I'm thinking about both sides of
the coin for us personally and but also
there I mean I'm assuming that we've got
you know there's just toilet paper on
shelves in businesses and there's toilet
paper on shelves in the warehouses that
supply the businesses because people
aren't using more toilet paper
I mean I'm eating more beans so maybe I
mean I'm more yeah I'm using a lot less
just out of principle but yeah there's
like there's all these sheltered
businesses and they're like full of that
single ply crap that the that the
corporation's pay for we don't do that
single plug crap at a mythical
entertainment we're all stupid that's
why people businesses are freakin
boarding up there their windows and
stuff because yeah I heard that in New
York City there's like a 75% increase in
business burglaries yeah what the crap
what the crap in the midst of this you
got people I think they'll probably get
true looking for the single-ply but you
know what's probably gone down
residential burglaries I don't think
there's more I would doubt that there's
more crime I think what we're talking
about is actually in my neighborhood
Christie said that like in the next door
app there people are going around and
welcoming on door handles and stuff yeah
yeah cars I mean breaking in homes yeah
yeah because that would be stupid
burglars arey visited Ferg lers gone a
burglar right and so they got a brother
somewhere and so they're gonna grill her
they're gonna go to business this is do
you want to answer some of these
questions yeah let's get into the
questions but first let's make a
promotion for mythical society calm
we're still open for business
we are not shuttering our our pipelines
are still open so we're we're releasing
new stuff I mean we got this be your
mythical best this one this one benefits
charity a portion of the proceeds so go
and browse over there there's some
there's some feel-good stuff there's
some look good stuff there's some all
types of ways to rep your boys and order
a little something that you can look
forward to getting in the mail you know
it's like we're home so much more the
stuff that I order there it's
supercharged with it with positivity now
of course I got a white wipe the boxes
down and leave them in the garage but
like it's nice to look forward to
getting something Lando ordered a new
scooter he's excited oh and you know
what he was gonna get us here they've
been talk even he went to oh he is yeah
he went after he ordered a scooter he
went into Lincoln through me said
Lincoln you want a new scooter I'll buy
you one hahaha I'm logged in he's logged
in and he's loaded with he's got so much
birthday money you don't know what to do
from the grandparents he bought his
brother scooter I actually think I
bought it because I didn't want probably
his money that was very kind but anyway
mythical calm in Ilana during a lot of
the the clothing that we have at
mythical calm incidentally
is very comfortable I mean we don't have
anything at this point that you couldn't
just put on and lay down in I mean
obviously there's a little there's a lot
of coated on clothing and lay it down so
mythical dot-com do that we also got a
new bumper sticker be nicer to people
right big fan of that all right yeah
let's know if you put it on your car
maybe somebody won't burglar your car
because I'll see that be like I'm should
be nicer to this guy move on to the next
car let's get into some some hearings
from you and simians you want to read
the first one or first - yeah these are
kind of a pair so cam kasia's cam says
again this is what are you doing to get
to the quarantine I gave myself a daily
chore slash project slash workout sheet
and follow it to a tee today's events
include jump rope push-ups catalogue
comic books and hang some floating
shelves it helps keep a sense of
schedule Wow cam bring in the schedule
heat now I'm relating to cam on the
other end of the spectrum we've got
Jamie always who says not doing all the
things I'd hoped I would do I imagined I
would be drawing every day and catching
up all my podcasts instead I've shaved
the sides of my head done in this
personality tests and lay on my couch
thinking deep thoughts for hours at a
time yeah I think that you know what's
the same of the the well laid plans of
men a poop in the net as bar at 1:00 in
the fire you know I I can kind of relate
to both of these because I'm I'm very
much a planner you know that I'm I'm
very system oriented and immediately
when I knew we were gonna be hunkering
down like even the few days leading up
to it I wasn't thinking about what am I
going off what am I gonna stock up on I
was thinking about schedule I was
thinking about routine I was thinking
about all the things I was gonna infuse
into my life and I just felt like I had
some
opportunity and now that we're I don't
know is this three weeks in this is a
faltering a little bit it is the fourth
week we're in the fourth week now yeah
because we started we started I think a
little bit earlier but to me having
having a routine is nuttin snow sprite
surprise to you is is is a lifeline for
me because I just I need to I need to
channel my energies and so I'm I made up
my mind that you know I'm gonna I'm
gonna buckle down on my meditation I'm
gonna get up every morning and I'm gonna
I'm gonna meditate I'm gonna I'm gonna
do my physical therapy stretches and I'm
gonna work out in my normal life I would
be able to choose one maybe two of those
each day but there's no way I could do
all three because again I got excited
about that I got ya I got excited about
that and then I was like I'm gonna I've
got this book on tape that I'm gonna
listen to and I'm gonna really be
engaged I'm gonna take notes and I got
another book that I'm gonna be reading
and I just started thinking about these
things and then I I was getting excited
but then some of it goes by the wayside
the stuff that's like the first morning
stuff I've been able to do like I'm I'm
pretty I'm pretty happy that I've I've
done 16 days of meditation in a row like
the most I've ever done it
I most I've ever done in a row is like
three days so I feel like I got a lot of
momentum and the app I use it's like it
tells me what how long my streak is so
it especially at this point I'm pretty
motivated to stick with it cuz man I
hate to start over and try to get to 16
again yeah that's why they do that yeah
it that that type of thing really works
for me
jumping rope I don't know how to jump
rope I have done some push-ups I don't
collect comic books but floating shelves
now that that's something I mean and you
saw the vlog so I've done you know I've
throw myself into cleaning yeah just a
little bit what mean what about you well
how do you relate to this I mean you
know I I don't know I I am I'm not a
planner but I am a doer you know I I
think there's a there's a there's a
there is a difference a lot most of the
time they coincide right because if
you're like well if you don't set out a
plan what are you gonna do I just find
myself doing a lot of things but not
Ness
Doug once I start doing things and start
realizing there's a lot of things that I
want to do then I start understanding oh
well you should plan so you can figure
out the order that you want to do these
things in and you know you want to
prioritize them you actually want to
make them happen so I think the thing
that's been happening to me is the first
couple of weeks I was thinking oh this
is actually there's this like
involuntary slowing down of everything
that I think is ultimately something
that I can take advantage of you know
personally professionally I mean there's
a lot of things that I did a lot of work
that I'm trying to do personally stuff
that I talked about in therapy but a lot
of times it ends up being the kind of
thing that I make some progress and have
a great conversation and then I actually
I go to therapy every two weeks and so I
just won't think about things very very
many times between those two weeks and
then from a professional standpoint I
mean I know you and I are always kind of
sitting back and evaluating what what
our strategy is and what we're doing and
what we're trying to accomplish
specifically what we're trying to create
the long term sort of comprehensive plan
for mythical entertainment and again a
lot of times what happens with those
things is we get into doing something
and then that planning which may happen
at the beginning
the year the end of the year is uh yeah
we turns out that we had great intention
and we actually fulfilled some of these
goals and we executed some of this plan
but we didn't really check back in with
it because we just got busy doing right
so I was excited about this this for
slowed down as a time to journal more
read more meditate more from a personal
standpoint there's a few things I'm kind
of working through like it's
establishing what my you know values are
and just some things like I want to sort
of submit and then from a professional
standpoint we've been talking about
figuring out like hey we've got this
down time where we from what we can do
as a business right now is well we can
keep making content and kind of keep our
folks busy but we also have an
opportunity to figure out like well when
things get back to normal what do we
want our business to look like where we
want it to go in the rest of 2020 and
2021 and beyond so I was very excited
about that but then I quickly found that
I was also like you know I don't really
have to get up at the same time you know
I usually get up at 5:50 in order to
stretch eat get to the gym didn't get to
work yeah and the idea of getting up at
5:50 right now feels ridiculous right
the first week I was going to bed at
about 11 o'clock which is interestingly
which is about when I usually go to bed
but I was waking up at like 8:00 yeah
and I was like oh that's nine hours of
sleep and I don't and it feels good and
I was like is that my body telling me
that that's how much sleep I should have
been getting all along but could we over
the course of these past few weeks maybe
because my body is adjusting but also
because I feel like I can't get used to
getting up late and also now that we are
kind of entering into a schedule of
creating our content and planning and
doing all these things I've moved it to
seven so I kind of slowly moved that
wake up time to seven and I am
doing it's actually so recording this on
a Tuesday and this week was the week
that I was finally like alright I kind
of need to get some things in place
because I want to meditate everyday I
want to workout it every day I want to
read and I want a journal every single
day I want to do those four things and
so yesterday I did all four before we
did any work this morning I did the
meditation and the exercise before we
did this but so I don't know I kind of
feel like I'm somewhere in the middle
like I get this this idea of like I'm
sick I sit down and I have these
intentions and I want an it this whole
idea that I want to draw like I have
that procreate app on the the iPad which
basically turns your iPad into in
skinless canvas right with every I mean
it's incredible the stuff that you could
do on there and I was actually sitting
outside meditating over the weekend and
I was doing a thing where you kind of
focus on the sounds that you could hear
and I don't know it's this is kind of a
synesthesia things I think most people
have if you really think about it but
like I've always since I was a kid when
I hear a sound I have a mental picture
of what that sound looks like not a
waveform but just it's there sort of
it's represented in something like a
high sound is represented in a certain
way and a low sound and a round sound
and a bird chirping and they if you
really dig into your mind you can kind
of oh I'm actually seeing something and
so I was like I want to create a
procreate project that visualizes the
sounds both color and shape that I am
experiencing in this meditation moment
where I hear the road and the cars and
the trucks and then a bird you know my
family behind me in the house talking or
whatever and I like sat down to do that
in about seven minutes in I was like I'm
not gonna do this that's a good idea man
no no can do that well I started to do
it and it became more difficult than I
wanted it to be in order to kind of
capture I think I will go back to it cuz
I really liked the idea because I really
liked the idea of doing it and then
the cool things about the procreate app
not a sponsor is that you can do a
time-lapse video of anything that you
drew it's constantly recording all your
stroll that's cool so theoretically you
could play it back and then I could
actually bring it into a video editing
program and put the corresponding sounds
as they're painted and it would do it
man
awesome videos just because you haven't
doesn't mean you can't now strike it's a
great idea but then it ends up getting
superseded by things like work work yeah
I mean we're still working a lot I'm
surprised at how much we're working I'm
also surprised that even though I've had
a lot of ideas like I told you yesterday
I just felt so unmotivated like more
unmotivated than I then I can recall
ever feeling just kind of feeling blue
just like a little I guess a little
depressed you know and just trying to
put my finger on what that is and I mean
the thing that I relayed to to our to
the mythical team because we had our our
company-wide meeting yesterday would try
to have one of those every two weeks so
that we're just kind of giving people
everyone an update and making sure that
we all connect and we were all in the
same page but you know the advice I gave
them was basically the advice I was
trying to take for myself which is from
week to week it's not like you just
figure out your approach to this just
like everybody's saying in the news
there's a there has to be a fluidity and
a flexibility to this there also has to
be a sensitivity to how am i doing from
day to day and is the way that I'm
approaching this and is the lifestyle
that I'm adopting is it the healthiest
for me does it position me to care for
myself and and care for other people and
to cultivate kindness I mean I you know
I'm sure we'll get into it eventually if
not today but the challenges of being in
such close proximity with your immediate
family is
yes it is trying it's difficult and it's
in it's hard too
we were we were talking to the kids last
night about what grace is and how we can
extend grace to each other but also
extend grace to ourselves and and just
continually assess is this working for
me and what do i what do I need to
change now as an inny Graham one I am I
am an improver right so I do think that
way but I also and I think that's that's
I think that's a healthy approach but I
also think I've had such a difficult
time because control is so important to
me and having a sense of accomplishment
every single day is very important to me
and when there's a lot of frustration I
just feel like so much of what we're
having to tackle professionally in this
new environment every time I turn around
there's a frustration in it and I might
cut my patience has been wearing so thin
and then I judge myself and I get I get
down on myself because I'm not relaxing
enough you're just at home you know
you're you're able to spend hours with
yourself before anybody wakes up and
like you're you're doing a great job at
that that should be making a difference
the rest of your day even the good parts
of what I'm doing I turn into a critique
of myself and I you know I don't know
that that's just one of process but you
know this interestingly it you know
you're one you know which is a
perfectionist and I'm a three which is
like a performer slash achiever and I
mean all the intagram numbers and again
we we sit we will do any agree Memphis
oh we say we would but the reason we
haven't done it yes because I just don't
like to speak out of school about things
and you know I don't feel like I've read
enough about it but anyway the you can't
perform it well enough yeah exactly but
one of them one of the interesting
things about
both ones and threes is there they're
both deeply self-critical right for
different reasons it's actually very
it's it's different but it's there's a
similar similarity to it because it has
to do with your performance like a one
is critical of how you're performing but
a three is very critical of how they're
performing as well and so I definitely
feel that I I feel we probably
experience it differently but I feel
this the same thing it's just like I'm
always you might be thinking am I doing
this right and I'm thinking am i doing
enough like that that's I tend to just
think about man I don't want this time
to have gone by and I don't have
anything to show for it you know because
my tendency as a three is to find my
self-worth and the things that I
accomplish so if I if I look at this
time that this downtime that we had it's
like oh this is an opportunity this is
an opportunity to get stuff figured out
to get yourself figured out to get your
business figured out to figure out what
your strategies are gonna be and to know
what you're going to accomplish figuring
out what you're going to accomplish and
I think that there's oh there is good in
that right I mean I think this is one of
the reasons that we've done a lot of the
things that we've done is because of the
way that our personalities
mix but both of us are kind of driving
towards accomplishing I'm kind of
driving towards accomplishing more and
you're driving towards accomplishing
things better
you know and yeah and I think that those
two things that one three combination is
a is a big key to a lot of things that
have happened for us but it also can be
you know a greatest strength is your
greatest weakness it can be our downfall
I one thing that was really helpful to
me the other day speaking of meditation
was in the guided meditation that I was
doing talking about kindness and
kindness to yourself
I think incidentally this is something
that growing up evangelical was a really
difficult thing for both of us I think
that we've always heard the term sort of
self-care and self kindness as an
inherently prideful and selfish thing
because everything had to be about
others first and I actually think that
if you really want others to be first
then you got to make sure that you're
that you're kind to yourself and you're
you're loving yourself not in this you
know self the whole the thing that we
began to learn in the 80s and 90s which
was all about everybody everybody's
special and everybody a all about your
self-image I'm not talking about that
but I'm just saying being kind to
yourself like one thing that struck me
in that meditation was treat yourself
the way that you would treat others
which what we hear a lot of times which
is the golden rule would treat others
the way that you would treat yourself
which is incredible thing we should all
live by it but there's a different way
to see that sometimes which is I tend to
be very gracious towards people like
when when I hear you talking about being
hard on yourself
for you know not feeling like you're
doing things right I'm like oh come on
man don't be so hard on yourself like my
natural inclination and I think most of
the people listening will beat it
hey give yourself a break but sometimes
it's very difficult to direct that type
type of grace back on yourself so for me
it was like just know that you're okay
you're you're accepted you know you you
you're not going to increase the love
that is available for you by the things
that you do and for the way that you do
them or for the way that you perform I
mean that's grace that's what grit
that's what it's one of the things I
love about the gospel is is the idea of
grace you got to be able to you gotta be
willing to extend that grace to yourself
it's not easy to do that yeah it's not
it's not yeah I I appreciate that and I
think you know let's put a pin in it and
let's move on to other questions but I
think that or other comments but it's a
good thing to continue to explore
as I continue to take the we take the
advice that we're giving to each other
you know yeah here's the ears one Erica
is lost in the music panoramic
underscore soul I've been spending more
time than usual with my guitar I mean we
know that must be true because we're
looking at where ad dollars are not
coming in for YouTube as much there's
been like a drastic decrease but we have
heard that unless you're like making
guitar videos yeah you know people are
buying ads on New Zealand on music
tutorials yeah she also said also my old
self my old self is trying this tik tok
thing and let me tell you i feel ancient
I'm sure you're not actually ancient
that's just that's just what tick tock
does when we're when we're a topping at
this point and I know that we both are
now we're exploring tick tock because we
have official mythical tick tock so I
said hey let's do a promo follow
mythical on tick tock or is it subscribe
see I don't even know what the word is
well it's funny I saw I don't know who
it was somebody commented when we posted
something about tick tock they were like
oh this is what the quest for relevance
has led to yes
you know it's my you know what that
person can kiss my butt well it you know
it's my ass this is what we do this is
what we make Internet content for a
living if you don't judge us for getting
on Facebook you might expensive why did
I say Facebook because you're all in
irrelevant
[Laughter]
I'm not on Facebook we're we're on
Facebook no we actually it's funny thing
is we've been talking we've been talking
a lot about tick-tock not just because I
feel like it's where Mike you know this
I mean that's what Locke is watching
more so than yeah to be at this point so
I think any sort of the onion teenager
is there and there's this very we talked
about this a number of times with each
other that the attitude that we've had
as we've gotten older towards emerging
platforms is every single time they come
along they are perceived first as an
annoyance because and if you're in the
digital entertainment business you see
them as a like an obligation it's like I
feel like we've got to do this because
like link said this is what we do and if
mythical doesn't have a presence in
these places then what are we doing
right but we haven't really seen those
as opportunities as much as we've seen
them as annoyances and obligations and
where one of the things that we're
trying to do during this time is to like
shift our shift the way we see it I mean
and there's always this point where you
step into it and there's sort of this
confusion and you feel old and you feel
out of touch you feel ancient like Erica
said because you're like I just don't
understand what this is about you're
telling me that the majority of this
content is these like girls and dudes
with very particular haircuts doing
these dances which are nothing like what
I'm actually doing right now because I
can't really - I don't know what they
are but then once you dig a little bit
deeper you're like well yes it is a lot
of that but beyond that there's some
like really legitimately engaging really
authentically funny stuff happening on
there and that's when I start getting
excited because I'm like oh I kind of
understand what people like about this I
find myself going on there not just as a
student but as a user you know as
someone who is just enjoying it like
everybody else and now there
shift happening towards what does it
look like from a creative standpoint so
yeah exciting yeah so um hey Erica just
stick with it a little bit you know you
can you find you find the right things
to to get interested in and you might uh
you might be excited for you to get past
the dancing and that's that's all I can
say is that yeah yeah I'm not the
dancing is not for me if you get past
that there's a there's a lot more
there's actually some like serious
content on there people like doing
self-help and stuff you know I was
reading about you know when when Drake
singled to see slide first came out you
know I was I was reading about it and he
he was working on this song and he
reached out to this this dance
choreographer to see who then said hey
I'm working on this song can you can you
put a dance to it cuz I did that's part
of the lyrics and then the way that it
three days before the song came out it
drops we're two one tick-tock in this
Innis them doing them doing the to see
slide which then I proceeded to I was
like you know what imma learn this and
then I did not have the courage to post
it anyway oh really
well you should've done that my Lincoln
and I were working on it my wife was not
impressed she actually went out of her
way to point out that she was not
impressed with the to see slide
she found it to be an underwhelming
dance well the the original version on
tik-tok looks great when people who
really know how to do it and invented it
do it
interestingly enough the audio in the
video I'm pretty sure out of sync which
and in terms of learning to dance it's a
little weird you know that discover some
but then you know it kind of melds as
other people start to do it and it
becomes not as not as impressed yeah
yeah you got to pop it and lock it you
got to keep it tight mm-hmm I don't even
watched it here's it there's a
Riverdance aspect to it let's move on
Emily Boswell Emily B writer said my
husband and I did a 2000 piece puzzle
and now that his
it feels like there's a hole in our
lives I think a lot of people are doing
pulses right now
well you're right Emily we had one at
the McLaughlin household and the puzzle
I believe this puzzle may haunt me until
the day I die but it's morally to finish
it it's more likely to haunt Jessi
because how many pieces fifty boys
involved 1,500 pieces so by far the
biggest puzzle that we've ever attempted
to do
did you already own it or did you order
it she ordered it because she was like
quarantine puzzle time you know hmm now
I saw folly in this result a puzzle yeah
yeah because you might guess this about
me but one of the things that makes me
like doing things is like nets yeah Nets
fire and poop is one thing but the idea
of there's some unpredictability about a
process or there's like insight or
something that can happen like I like
dynamic experiences and puzzles are by
default not dynamic or by design not
dynamic it is literally the same thing
from start to finish it is it is a
process that has you know exactly what
the end is gonna be because there's a
freaking picture that you're looking at
what's the discovery oh we made the
picture that's on the box
it isn't like there's a surprise when
you put it together oh no there's a
secret little animal that's in the
version that you put together which who
is by the way a good business idea
because then maybe people like me would
actually want to do puzzles but I just
don't like it's like it's like reading a
book twice it's something unless it's a
book about a concept that I need to
grasp better I don't like reading a
story again I'm not one of those people
because somehow I don't you get well I
was not involved at all
I saw them put it on the table and I was
like just to let you know I'm not into
puzzles it's not my thing and I don't
and I think by the end of it you'll also
realize it's not your thing cuz I know
my wife she's a lot like me I know she
ain't gonna want to do this puzzle but
over the course of two weeks we could
not you
our dining room table because this 1,500
piece monstrosity was being slowly put
together what was it a picture of it was
a picture and this is this is so
interesting they made it it wasn't just
a 1500 piece puzzle it was a 1500 piece
puzzle of a landscape with a house and a
barn reflected in a pond that was
reflecting every single thing that was
above the fold right so she had two it's
two puzzles it was
yes version a slightly a slightly
blurrier version of landscape reflected
in the pond I mean very very crisp for a
pond reflection but ever so slightly
blurry but not easy to tell when you
just take two little teeny pieces and
look at them say is this the blurry one
or is this not the blurry one so I knew
it was gonna be a complete mind screw
just by looking at it and then it had
large patches of grass and sky that were
there's no there's no point of reference
it's just that's all blue you should
start a YouTube channel let's say a
tick-tock you should start a tick-tock
I'll contribute puzzle quiz where you
review you review puzzles just based on
the box and all of them get a review of
0 out of 10 and you're just convincing
people not to build that puzzle you know
what this is a tick tock idea and I love
it don't do it
welcome to my puzzle review it as you
can see this one blah I give it a 0 out
of 10 okay and then you just rip it to
shreds I'm gonna do it with it and then
I'll make it and by the way at the end
of each one
you literally shred it you get some sort
of like big shredder and you put the
puzzle in the box and all the pieces and
use a paper shredder you do a puzzle
with a paper shredder great idea or burn
it burn it but its own that and burn it
but that didn't stop my wife from
repeatedly revisiting this and actually
there was a couple of times that I felt
sympathy for her and I sat down and
because it's staring you in the face and
every time you walk past your table
you've got this thing that's just like
thumbing its nose at you that you know
what you are inadequate you don't have
what it
takes to finish me right and that's why
I don't I don't like puzzles either by
the way because I don't like long-term
commitments when the chances of failure
are very very high well she didn't want
to admit failure like she went she got
so far into this thing over the course
of two weeks and there was one time that
I sat down and I just sat down and I
started looking at the way she'd
organized the pieces which is she had
now organized the pieces and so I was
just like you know why don't you and she
said don't judge me why she interrupted
me
hello she was like I've been working on
this you can't just sit down and begin
to point out why my technique is wrong
like I know you're about to do so I
didn't say anything else and I just kind
of selected a couple I saw it was a bit
like the bunch of window pieces as I
could put together this house and so I
got some of the window pieces and you
know over the course of about 20 minutes
or so I probably put like seven or eight
pieces together I mean that's how long
this thing takes I mean did she even
work the border first she worked the
border first she did do that he worked a
proto first yeah and but then when I
presented my little house that I put
together she said Thanks that's the easy
part
she was just like she she didn't even
accept the house I mean she did accept
the house she put it in there she didn't
take it but she finally gave just to
close the loop on the puzzle she finally
got to a place where all the parts that
had some sort of recognizable points of
reference were together and she was left
with this big piece of sky and this big
piece of grass and this big part of a
mountain just still Pike thirty percent
of the puzzle and she just had all these
pieces you didn't know which ones were
from the reflection or not the
reflection and they were you had to kiss
keep trying pieces over and over again
and it would look like they were gonna
fit and then she just took the thing put
it back in the box and we haven't talked
about it haven't talked about it oh
we're not gonna talk about she write it
in a box yeah I just went I went into
the kitchen I mean I went into the
dining room
there was no puzzle and I was like well
I think what happened to the puzzle
did you I said did you finish it I mean
she just said no I quit and we haven't
spoken since about it about it oh my god
okay here's here's one from katashi call
me Kat underscore underscore I've been
hoping so masks for the health
professionals out there I wanted to make
sure that we acknowledged not only Kats
work but everyone who's who's who's
doing things like this I mean I say
that's absolutely amazing Kat thank you
for being your mythical best yeah and I
think about all the health professionals
who are out there on the front lines and
I'll add one more from Jay at good
mythicality I've gone from working part
time to overtime at Walmart and when I
get home all I do is rewatch Toy Story 3
with my nephew he's 2 and manages to
forget the plot every time I am not so
lucky
yeah who could have thought who could
have thought that Walmart will be the
front lines for this thing I mean you
know there there are there are there are
people who are working stocking shelves
helping make sure that we get what we
need and are able to stay at home
delivery people there they're passing
away I mean they're not just getting
sick they're dying I mean it's it's
heart-wrenching and it's I mean when
it's not sensationalism to say that
they're the these people are the ones
that are on the front lines because you
know we're talking about how there's a
little bit of you know we're doing the
right thing by staying home but at times
you feel guilty because there's people
who you know they have to work and then
but their work requires them to do
something that's very much essential and
it put them it puts them in harm's way
well it was also like it's got to come
in and give a masks
is tremendous well and staying home is a
very privileged option and yeah and this
whole thing you know there are a lot of
people who don't have a choice I mean
some people I mean some people are just
still required to go to work whether or
not their particular business has been
deemed essential just because some
employers are doing that but like you
said I think that you've got your your
medical professionals and that's
everybody from you know the doctors and
the nurses and the janitors cleaning the
hospitals and the people supplying them
with the things that they need to do
their jobs and the people finding all
the essential services that keep that
going and then all the people who
provide the essential services that
allow us to just sit at home and do what
we're doing there's a reason that the
internet is working right now and I'm
able to communicate with you you know
it's there's people going in and
managing all this stuff to enable us to
have some sense of normalcy and I just
think that they're the real heroes and
that's a lot of people and if the only
thing you can do is do what we do which
is to stay home then that's actually
that you know that's you doing your part
because that is that's flattening the
curve is a huge important part of this
but yeah this I heard somebody say that
this is gonna be the kind of thing where
and it's interesting because I found
myself saying thank you for your service
to the UPS guy ya know what I'm saying
it's just like we we come from a you
know the way it's always been when we
think about patriotism as we think about
our country succeeding in war against
other countries and we think the
soldiers who fought for our freedom and
we should we shouldn't stop doing that
we shouldn't stop thinking soldiers but
this is much like a war and there is a
frontline and these people are the
soldiers
fighting and then there's the people
behind the scenes making it all happened
and so I think that the definition of
patriotism is changing and it's also
changing the way that we think about
this whole America first thing which has
become such a big thing politically it's
just like I understand the idea of a
national pride to some extent but I
think that one of the things that we've
been able to experience and having a
business that might be based in the
United States but a community of people
who watch what we do that knows no
borders there's a there's a very
international sense to this community of
people that have have gathered around
what we do and you just see their
perspective of where they're at and you
see the life that they're living and you
see that most people want the same
things out of life and you see that this
virus doesn't discriminate
this virus doesn't know about borders it
doesn't know about the imaginary borders
that we've drawn around ourselves it
doesn't know about the imaginary labels
that we've given ourselves and the
effort to combat it shouldn't have
borders around it when we think about
the idea of a cure and our president
says things like we've America's got the
best scientists in the world and we're
gonna find a cure it's like okay yeah
American scientists are great but
scientists are great is really what we
should be saying and the idea that we're
gonna not listen to the knowledge in
another place if they figured something
out and the funny thing is is I read an
article where scientists we're kind of
responding to that mentality they were
like saying science has never worked
that way we've never science it's not a
national thing because we know that if
you're doing a controlled experiment in
Japan and I'm doing a controlled
experiment in America we're gonna get
the same results if the same things go
into it and so we're the idea this
collective global effort to combat this
collective global problem I think is
something that you know we didn't get to
this last week when we talked about the
silver lining but that's a huge silver
lining from
it's just the idea that we continue to
realize that there is an incredible
interdependence between all humans and
these labor that we place on ourselves
are not helpful yeah and to bring it
back to Jay working at the Walmart I
mean I will think differently about my
my my male woman and my delivery guy and
the person stocking my shelves at the at
the rafts down the street you know and I
think that's that's very good you know
it's we tip we tip our waiters and
waitresses you know I'm gonna I'm gonna
do that differently you know I'm gonna
I'm gonna look for opportunities to look
people in the eye and to think them at
least that is my intention
so I'm going on podcast record to be
more appreciative of the people that
make everything run so again we do we
thank you if you're if you're listening
one of those people you're listening
you're on a route or your stock in a
shelf or you're you're taking care of
your grandkids so that your daughter can
be a doctor or a hospital janitor I mean
we there's so many people playing so
many critical roles and now more than
ever I appreciate that
how interconnected we all are just like
you're saying you want to what you think
you think you're gonna write you got a
wreck for us I do have a wreck this is a
wreck that we I we've talked about this
I don't know if you made this as a wreck
but you talked about on a read on a
podcast last year how you were going
back and watching Survivor as a family
and yeah our our Christmas our post
Christmas vacation year before last we
went to Sedona and we watched yeah right
survivor Millennials versus Gen X right
so Jessie was amazing
Jessie was on the call with her her
friends of which one is
wife and one of their collective friends
it said hey our family is really
enjoying this season of Survivor and you
know even when you talked about Survivor
I think I did why we watched a little
bit of a season but I just I haven't
been back into it basically since the
beginning but Jesse but there's
something when you're a family and
you're looking for things to do together
yeah a lot of times if that's not a
puzzle it might be on a screen and so
she was like hey Rebecca
and her family are watching the latest
disease in her survivor which is like
the 20th you know the 40th season the
20th anniversary or whatever and it's
all the winners we should watch it with
the kids I was like you know that's a
good idea it's it's a network show which
means there's gonna be like over 20
episodes they're each like an hour long
this feels like a good way to spend some
time together as a family and so we
started that we're like a few episodes
in I have to say that me and Jesse and
Shepard are the most into it it's been
difficult the whole house you have a 16
year old but now Lily Lily in Lincoln
both love it
over here well so lock will kind of get
into it a little bit and then Oh kinda
back off a little bit so oh so we'll see
we're gonna keep what we're gonna keep
doing it but I mean I'm into it in this
I you have to sort of acknowledge that
like I am watching survivor I'm okay
with that
thank you know and there's a nostalgia
to it and there is hey man I told you
before there's something for everyone
except apparently locked most of the
time I mean you got if if you're if
you're into men and women and basically
underwear and the in the bush or the
brush or careful wherever they are you
got that I I think I told you I was
really into the way that it's edited and
the way they tell a story even the even
the recaps at the beginning of an
episode if you were to binge watch and
you would just watch the previous
episode the recaps are great because
they they
don't recycle footage they reveal a
little different angle on the same
things that you already experienced it's
like it it's a really really well-made
show everything down to the drone shots
and the the the score changes from
season to season it's funny that the
difference in our approach because I
made the decision we made the decision
of the family to dive back into survivor
2 but then I like I said I'm gonna I'm
gonna go away and do some research and
I'm gonna come back with which episode
we should watch and what our plan should
be and for us that was let's not watch
the current season let's watch let's
start with season 17 which is in Gabon
Africa it's the first HD season and then
from there I mean I read a number of
articles that like make recommendations
about which seasons are good and if some
of the best seasons you kind of have to
watch a season before if you really want
to know the characters that they're
bringing back and so we've taken the
extreme long-term approach that I have
if we're gonna be in this for for a
couple of years which we're not we're
not
then I think I have like seven seasons
we could watch and of course I don't
know we're the Neil's we might actually
do that yeah that we would never do that
in that way
I understand watching this season that
I'm gonna know who the winners are but I
just don't think there's a world in
which we're gonna there's like over 20
episodes just of this season I'm not
gonna yeah I'm not gonna go back and do
it again I don't think based on based on
the reaction so far I am still
recommending it yeah you should try it
because I recommend you can watch as a
family so you're saying recommend the
current one I'm recommending starting
with season 17 and then working up to
heroes vs. villains and you can read
articles make sure that you check
spoiler free before use too too much
research alright alright I agree with
that wreck hashtag your biscuits let us
know
let's continue the conversation online
until we speak at you next week yeah
thanks for listening as always to watch
more ear biscuits click on the playlist
on the right to watch the previous
episode of your biscuits click on the
playlist to the left and don't forget to
click on the circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms thanks for being your
mythical best